[Music]
[Music]
i'm francisco and let me welcome you
here tonight and let me start by calling
on mr. drake Mitchell of the student
disarmament study group we would like to
make an announcement mr. Mitchell
on behalf of the MIT students torment
study group I'd like to bring to your
attention their project we've been
working on for quite a while within
hours of reaching fruition if you're
interested in speaking with your
Congressman about arms race issues now's
your chance
Massachusetts students staff and faculty
will be joining with thousands from
across the nation tomorrow for a day of
lobbying in Washington DC buses will be
leaving MIT at 11:00 p.m. this evening
after day at the Capitol were live back
in Boston early Friday morning cost is
$30 all the opponents have been made
with senators representatives and their
aides for all the states in her nation
if you're interested please read outside
of lecture hall after this evening's
activities and after that there will be
a reception for all the Massachusetts
lobbyists in room 407 of the Student
Center the trip should be quite exciting
and a worthwhile experience for all so
thank you
let me welcome you again my name hasn't
changed so I welcome you to this year's
Compton lecture tonight we mark the 40th
year since the explosion of the first
nuclear device in the New Mexican desert
eleven present and retired MIT
professors were involved in that effort
at Los Alamos that culminated in that
event hence the title of today's set of
talks and things happening thirty years
after Los Alamos MIT in the bomb halos
MIT faculty members are here tonight to
see in that title a reflection of the
commitment of so many members of mi
t--'s community to doing something about
the situation in which we in the world
find ourselves these veterans who are
here tonight in that activity their work
throughout these 40 years to contain the
effects of their terrible invention made
war obsolete but unfortunately it did
not make one impossible the existence of
nuclear weapons poses the greatest
threat since nemesis to the survival of
life on Earth and if not life on Earth
at least the survival of our of our
civilization civilization as we know it
I hope that the meeting tonight will
help us think food 40 and usefully about
what we can do about these terrible
questions we
that the joy reasoner will be unable to
join us mrs. reasoner is in the hospital
it's not it's not life-threatening but
she is confined for the moment confined
leaving hospital today in Florida and he
had to be with her and he sends his best
wishes and regrets so we will hear
tonight from the two other scheduled
speakers after their talk well we are
also honored to have with us tonight mr.
budge spade who's the Ambassador from
India to true Washington after their
talk I will ask him for a few comments
and after that we will open the meeting
to two general discussion the two
speakers are both old friends of mine
and of many of us here
I can't imagine two different people but
when I think of how I should introduce
them I have not been given a prepared
veto I mean actually their vetoes are so
long and so distinguished that one
couldn't do much with it anyway the same
things come to mind extraordinarily
different people they are both
physicists they're both distinguished
physicists there are MIT Institute
professors they are incredibly
humane humanists
[Music]
and of course after they after they talk
you tell the difference and and titles
the first then
[Applause]
[Applause]
my friends 40 years after
inspired in the historic explosion which
some of you saw this afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for I and many others there took our
dark glasses being he figured out that
the intensity should be roughly twenty
midday sun's at that distance and the
efficiency and so on it was an awesome
experience and become shape and and then
the Sun actually certainly incredible
impression unique achievement and
certainly with misgivings about the
future of mankind three weeks after that
trials two bumps two cities in Japan
whatever one may think about the wisdom
saved
many more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes more than necessary mental
disease but being aware is not enough
[Music]
[Music]
there are many kinds of fear there is
for example the fear of a first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so it and given the destructive power
even one submarine it is playing the
first strike just up to the 70s very
easy to say the least but let me say
that this increase of the Russian
nuclear weapons which happened in the
second part of the 70s and beginning of
the 80s
I just
and to the arms race why because you
never know and there's a lot of secrecy
particularly on the other side and
therefore you
worst and to think there are more
weapons there and therefore has to build
more and build them up
this is one of the driving forces of
course of the arms race the second the
third fear actually is distances most
distance in a certain type for example
in Russians have actually more
land-based we have war submarine weapons
so we think we have to have the same
number of land-based missiles and the
Russians have those big land-based
missiles and that is one reason why
people want to build the MX and the s
the Soviet Union of course on the other
side is going to build submarines
because they have fuel that we are this
is again a mechanism for escalation
themselves in southeast
but this is seen by the other side is a
defensive action to ensure the security
of their borders when Vietnam questions
to establish a counterbalance to the
influence of China
conversely US has a lot of defensive
actions to prevent the spread of
communist influence for example in
Central America Middle East and these
are perceived of course by the Soviet
Union is an attempt to build up Western
influence wherever possible and the
recent Star Wars is a typical example it
is perceived by the Soviet Union as a
preparation for first strike because
then we can have a first strike and
build at least the consequences of a
retaliation will be diminished so that
he can perhaps
I don't believe that perhaps believe so
each military and political action
abroad can be interpreted as aggressive
or defensive by one side and during
crisis of course such missing
presentations
the lack of understanding comes across
from a very completely different system
social system political system we are
afraid of the authoritarian regime world
communism the lack of elementary human
rights on the other side the treatment
of minorities suppression of freedom in
satellites and that arouses fears in the
United States and vice versa the
ideology of capitalist free enterprise
human right activities virulent
anti-communism strong support of
right-wing dictators and lately in the
talk about liberating the world
necessarily arouses fear in the Soviet
Union
you're not only now in order to
understand the fears and the subsequent
actions of our adversary we must
consider the present situation let me
express this way there are four large
power complexes China United States
three of them have one enemy let me say
adverse adversary the Soviet Union one
of them the Soviet Union has four mainly
the three others and its own population
now it's no laughing matter for them and
this explains a lot of actions for
example one of the reasons certainly one
of the reasons of the large conventional
forces is the fear of revolts in Eastern
Europe the overly large number of Soviet
ss-20 missiles is probably meant to
deter the Western eighty-four revolts
impossible revolts in Eastern Europe and
to support incipient anti Soviet
government
the fact that the West never has
supported such movements is does not
away their fears that they may do it in
the future
now these fears are important but they
are not the only cause of the armaments
race I am coming now to another very
dangerous and important more and more
important cause of the armament race and
that is the increasing momentum of the
military machine years of intense
development and build-up of weapons of
means of deliveries of new methods to
improve the accuracy they have
established an interval system of vested
interests of ambitious and dedicated
groups unwilling to give up their
successful activities not very much
because of financial interests but also
because when natural commitment to
pursue a difficult task just when it's
about to yield more and better results
no doubt most participants believe that
they will that what they do will enhance
the security of the United States or of
the Soviet Union but it's probably not
so how can an armament race increases
security it I remember this very well
from personal experience in the Solomons
I think this afternoon there was a
little discussion but I will still
mention it now namely in the Solomons we
all love to be most of us like myself
and many of my friends went to Los
Alamos only because we are afraid that
Hitler will make the bomb still when the
bomb when Hitler was defeated just about
40 years ago in May there wasn't even
discussion of quitting we just worked on
because we had also this technological
momentum that Oppenheimer uses this
uncanny term take a technically sweet
project
that's dangerous of course the same
danger of this momentum is also in our
preparations for both sides preparation
for it with aging in nuclear war that
strategies tactics are developed an
escalating search for military targets
to be hit in case and the more such
targets are found and more bombs have to
be deployed to hit them should the
deterrence fail so goes the augment
nuclear war made by comment we must be
prepared to prevail in a limited nuclear
war but of course nuclear very probably
cannot be limited the losing site has it
will be forced to escalate to art shops
facing when another saying the tighter I
draw the bow the safer I become
unfortunately also these paper rations
are fueled by their own momentum the
more developments going on the more
possibilities of attacks are found as I
said the more precious developed for
deployment and such preparations made a
certain sense in the past when war was
really acceptable as the last resort for
which one must be well prepared in my
hometown in Vienna there is a monument
and it says on the monument si vis pacem
para bellum for those who don't know
Latin it means when you wish for peace
prepare for war
today the slogan can no longer be
applied to prepare for nuclear war is to
prepare for mood mutual suicide so the
arms race is the product of irrational
fears felt by both contending powers
and there is a self-perpetuating
mechanism that creates it all momentum
and increases the fears and draws all
the activities into its world pool and
this is why the present confrontation is
so dangerous that is the first part of
my talk now I would like to use the rest
of the time through those thoughts that
must come to people who are involved
with these questions what have we
learned from what happened in the last
40 years and how can we see a hopeful
future which I do I I don't believe at
least I feel my bones that we won't be
all discard but only if we do something
about it now the last four decades one
important lesson negotiations to reduce
the level of nuclear weapons have very
little chance of success in the
prevailing atmosphere of confrontation
distrust and increasing offensive and
defensive weapon developments on the
contrary there is a danger of the
erosion of even those few few treaties
that did slow down the armaments race
like salt 1 and salt - perhaps I should
like to make your remark so one has an
interesting part which many of you know
namely the ABM Treaty which says that
you are not supposed to defend yourself
against strategic missiles so quite so
you are allowed to have one or two
in two establishments for that actually
United States has not used it at all and
the Russians have one Moscow now this
was a very difficult development and I
remember at that time I was active in
the park Vash movement from 64 that
treaty was concluded in the 70s 72 from
64 armed
we tried to talk with Russian scientists
to tell them that such defenses are
dangerous because all they will do is to
increase the number of offensive
warheads so that an equilibrium so
called equilibrium is established it was
difficult to convince the russians
indeed the russian scientists use the
same arguments which you hear today from
our government
I mean defense obviously is good you
know how can defense be bad we must
defend ourselves and and it took us many
years but we succeeded not only to
convince the scientists our government
at that time was also of that opinion
and the scientists that came to publish
of course had very strong connections
with their government or they wouldn't
be allowed to come out to the west and
they were able to convince the
government to sign that treaty which to
some extent has reduced the speed of the
armaments race that it didn't turn it
around but the interesting thing I tell
this only because of the application of
for today today the situation seems to
be reversed the same group of scientists
that convinced at that time the Russian
scientists that defends that that kind
of defense against missiles will only
increase the armaments race do not they
are not successful in convincing our
present government of this and vice
versa the Russians now who we had a hard
time to convince now say exactly that
idea and repeated
and previous a good certification well
this is just to say that I mean there
were certain efforts are also already
already before these during these 40
years but there is now a chance at all
these treaties I wrote it for example
the star war project good if it actually
goes into the testing and development
phase would have would be a breach of
the ABM Treaty which has saved us so far
from too much development now is there a
chance that we can arrive at a we must
there are compelling reasons that is
sort of clear to everybody but must be
regarded not as weapons of war but the
only purpose is to deter their use by
the other side and for this of course we
have much fewer than we have change
those causes which I've analyzed before
of increasing efforts
[Music]
[Music]
for example every action on both sides
should be examined on the other side
examples in the perception
therefore we must not only strive to
maintain an offensive defensive parity
because one little remark
one could say AHA so far ahead that we
can become superior and they cannot
follow us that would be the most
dangerous situation because
[Music]
those people who have to discuss
[Music]
intermediate-range missiles in Europe or
Cuba as missiles against us I mean
so should be because the very much in
[Music]
the standings of the 20% without
because we can't use them anyway because
against Europe and no sense at all on
the country some of them who are
speakers Hiroshima explosions some of
you have seen this afternoon is a very
good chance of a successful negotiation
on that because actually the US has
already reduced nuclear conflagration so
these are all small measures what is
necessary and certainly that the last 14
years have shown that is to reduce
tension by by more effective methods we
need a deeper change of attitude
[Music]
and the in the in the world for example
the the ice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which of two other the experience of the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
understanding of the psychology of the
adversary compromise was much in
evidence during the last
but on an absolute
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Vicki the next speaker is
Professor Philip Morrison
[Applause]
discussion any of the 18,000 yards 10
miles must have had the same experience
the site was awesome the sound prepared
by the calculations and discussions we
had had where's the sense of worth on
the face just a fraction of a second or
a second this is an experience because
of course that kind of sense with such a
wide channel of input is something that
you remember beyond the vision beyond
the sound beyond the rational and
awesome consequences that we could draw
two of my old colleagues at the asylum
it's wonderful I figures in this room
have much impressed by the same memory
[Music]
the possible wisdom having an occasional
ceremonial above-ground test device
somewhere in the desert in the Pacific
the heads of state are the
representatives so two might be base
camp
ten miles away and feel the heater in
the face this may be very in generous
view of how statesman's minds are
changed but it is not without its
persuasiveness as usual my case studies
which is the way I could deal with
history and I would like to tell you
something through China's failed into by
the persuasiveness of another colleague
professor zacharias I was caused by his
persuasion to go Oklahoma City I shall
describe all this doesn't a chance to
meet articulate people with that kind of
extensive historical experience things
quite straight so for us the twentieth
century begins in 1896 now in January
1896 this man was a young student in the
freshman physics course at Colorado
College
and his professor came in that morning
having seen the paper and said and
rakhumai news is coming the newspaper
today I was planning and were supposed
to do something wonderful through the
skeletal shape here in the entire so
indeed they and the others
[Music]
[Music]
and it's crystallization to make it
appear a nucleus you have to drop it
now exactly the same situation I only
realized this the last couple of months
preparing lectures for our course
exactly the same situation applied to
discovery of nuclear fishing when
fishing was described correctly by
Meitner and Bohr in terms that they
worked out on Christmas vacation in 1938
and was announced the world across the
world from Japan to the Soviet Union
every place where there was a halfway
respectable department of physics
interest was able to duplicate the
effect right away and in a couple of
days show the fish and pulses on an
oscilloscope to anybody who would ask
pulses 50 times more intense than the
pulses from alpha particle emission
which was quite common to see in the
same display so you see this is the
example of two cases I know of no others
really like that two cases where
fundamental change occurred in a sense
long overdue the community was ready for
it the instruments had been used widely
and developed for the purpose the crooks
tube was available everywhere
photographic plate was available
everywhere there was no problem just the
right combination had not been found and
once that combination was given and the
same thing happened with fission many
people failed to discover fish in three
years before one in the three years
before was discovered by this earth at
small failure which just chance led them
to put extra piece of scotch tape across
the sample an actual case not to be able
to turn the knob far enough in the
design spectrograph to catch the energy
of the next x-ray line a number of other
events like that which prevented this
the premature so to speak discovery
efficient so that in a way and this is
again with Vicki said that matter has
the property of the release large-scale
release of nuclear energy and it came to
us
extraordinary discovery but it came of
course in a different context was not
1896 but early 1939 World War began in
late 1939 and was sealed most people
feel by the Munich events of the fall of
in 1938 this we felt all over just in
California where I was within a month
after the first heard of fission I
myself remember and I was no expert and
did not understand except in the most
elementary way the nature of Neutron
diffusion drew on the board in Licata
219 which we'd graduate students shared
in the anteroom of Robert Oppenheimer a
drawing of a nuclear weapon with the
keywords deuterium and chain and all
those things that you might now
associate with it
they're very naive it worked but it was
not the result of serious effort it was
just what was in the air
it was the climate and so it seems very
difficult to avoid the conclusion that
we're in for it one way of another to
face this problem what did happen as a
consequence of this strange chance was
the close coincidence between the
opening of this possibility and the
outbreak of the most of the war of war
stimulated by the most virulence of self
declared aggressive regime in the
history of Europe for centuries this was
a peace perhaps of bad luck
total war was implied by the headlines
of the events and here was the device
embryonic device suited intrinsically to
that particular activity and that
perhaps a historical tragedy which we
could not have control but which we
certainly have to recognize now the
institutions that are responsible for
this are the most dominant institutions
that our lives they have been so for
300 years about that's not as old as
modern science which goes back now about
400 years but these three or four
centuries have seen the simultaneous
growth of the two most important
institutions of contemporary life finals
playing what they are they are nations
national states on the one hand and
science and it's conscious application
technology on both ways on the other
hand these two institutions represent
the modern world in many ways and if you
look at the pages of the books of
history you'll see them on every page
increasingly strongly as the centuries
have combined
they have very different ideals they
have very different origins one speaks
for diversity universality the other
speaks for adherents coherence pride in
the limited community true size of the
luteal with specialization has lost some
of its universality specialization both
in place it in nature but of course the
national state in fact I saw that
perhaps has become somewhat larger but
still is primarily much in the form that
the revolutionaries of France or the
United States for that matter would have
recognized as the formation of a nation
and nation building and nation forming
has never been more vigorous than it has
been since the energies released first
after World War one when the great
empires of Europe crashed and then World
War two when the great empires that held
colonial sway across the countries also
crashed in their turn now in the days
the Enlightenment it's hard to believe
how these two institutions fitted with
each other and it's very difficult to
satisfy yourself that it's the same way
you know from the present day that it's
that way but it was that way and there
many reasons I don't know that break
them much even see them themselves but I
just want to mention to when Captain
Cook sets sail his wonderful expedition
to explore thus look for a southern
continent measure the transit of Venus
and explore the Pacific for
his majesty our country which was at war
with Great Britain Revolutionary War in
full energy through its brilliant
scientific ambassador to Paris mr.
Franklin wrote a letter to all our
commanders at sea saying by no means
attack Captain Cook's vessel give him
free passage he sails not as a British
ship not as a ship of the British Navy
but as a representative of science what
he does will only enhance the virtues to
all mankind including the United States
of America and gave him safe conduct
it's hard to believe that what happened
today even even later even later when
Colonel William Lambton was engaged by
the East India Company not even the
British state but an agent of the state
the East India Company to begin the
great triangulation which has led to the
modern Indian survey beautifully mapped
from emolia's to the Cape his great
fundamental fee on light that was to be
used to establish the principal geodetic
coordinates was sent by sea and captured
by a French ship a disaster no three or
four years later no great delay in the
circumstances of 18 8 or 1810 when it
was it appeared by courtesy of the
French Academy who said they had no
interest in depriving Colonel Lambton of
his wonderful instrument there it was
please use it publish the maps well it
was a time you may say was in genuine of
course it was a time when science did
not have the power did not generate the
power yet the power was of course in the
hands of Armorer's always had been but
there was technology and not yet much
influenced by the the more rational
abstract qualities that we see in most
Galilean science
nowadays of course the figure of the
earth is a top military secret and if
you know where there are concentrations
of mass and changes of the geoid
that haven't yet been worked out from
the satellite perturbations you better
not tell anybody because it's very
important for directing the missiles and
against it is this exponential rise of a
powerful means of understanding and thus
controlling features of the environment
these two great changes interlock and
something new entered with nuclear
weapons which which I maintain are
special with the dangerous position to
maintain but I think it is a real one is
verifiable in some sense quantitatively
they are not ordinary people have always
wondered at the expressions of energy
and of course in terms of sheer total
energy we still can't match the energy
is released in nature the philosophers
of Hellenic and Hellenistic times
recognized energy and gravitation
falling bodies in the winds and the
water currents the waves of the ocean of
course they don't have the power density
which we command in nuclear explosions
they recognize a second kind of energy
evident animus energy the energy
characteristic of human beings their own
motion and the motion of all the animals
in fact a sign of motion we still think
of something animated when it is moving
and the notion that mechanical objects
would also move came as a strange and
marvelous thing at the two thousand
years ago and even five three or four
hundred years ago it was still quite
remarkable that motion could be
transferred from living things or mere
forces of nature where it was intrinsic
to move like wind and waves to little
clockwork objects we've lost that sense
entirely today so I think I said earlier
in this very room there's a parallel
today which has to do with intelligence
mechanical objects and there are two
people are puzzled and associated I
think it's very likely the same
consequence to occur namely it will be
transferred to mechanisms and we won't
understand those mechanisms and those
are actually not enables to understand
intelligence in ourselves any more than
the motion wind-up mice and able to
understand my very well it's a very
small part of the problem but the power
in nuclear explosives as everyone's
pointed out is extraordinary but this is
the fundamental point the fundamental is
not only the power that can be summoned
there of course they pile up enough TNT
you compile energy but you can't do that
you can't do that economically it is the
extraordinary cheapness of nuclear
energy and explosive form that is the
characteristic danger of the situation
I must be twenty years ago I was riding
in an airplane one night late flight and
I had bought a copy of the familiar
magazine The New Yorker looking at the
cartoons I was startled to find a
cartoon which was based on the following
conceit of a clever cartoonist
it was the time in Soviet Russia Soviet
Chinese different since in the early 60s
and the cartoon showed a gentleman jINSA
of the Chinese a Mandarin at one of the
Mandarin 8th alerted Mandarin eight
impassive in his robes and waving the
appropriate fan and so all made very
chinoiserie and then a bunch of toiling
people in their blue uniforms you could
see that making a great firecracker and
the caption said they test we test and
that was the idea of the cartoonist
now the firecracker was gigantic it was
about you know as big as a house
35 or 40 feet diameter and it was drawn
perhaps 150 200 feet long and toiling
men were carrying a great thing to light
it that's you can see the exaggeration
the cartoonist but you recognize that if
I were try to make a Megaton of
gunpowder just must be what they use at
firecrackers the firecrackers represent
that would have to be a 30-foot diameter
tube but would not just be 200 feet long
or 2,000 feet long or 2 miles long or 20
miles long would actually go right
across the horizon at a few megatons and
disappear into space like the Great Wall
it's hyperbolic the cartoons matter
artists that he knew if he drew that
people think was impossible but it's
simple sense and that's the trouble and
very hard to imagine that trouble if you
can't calculate it and face it and even
when you've seen it it's not easy to
imagine if that's the situation as
everyone knows this is this take a
freight train world with boxcars of TNT
from rattles by it'll carry a Megaton by
at full speed past your gray crossing in
eight hours
that's a Megaton
the disposition of the forces now gives
each side a yield of between five and
ten geiger turns five and ten thousand
megatons each side this is an ordinance
it doesn't compare to any of the other
structures in our society and that's why
I think it was fair to say that it
represents a novel danger not to be
compared to the terrible history of war
between nations which indeed is bad
enough and in human terms cannot be
dismissed or diminished who is to think
otherwise and to read all these grave
things even though at the same time they
brought out courage and sacrifice and
unity in the usual way that nationalism
has built for us who could not hope for
an end to war who would not extreme
series of all time ever since we've had
States it's not intrinsic probably to
human beings but to the organization and
States but I think we have at the moment
I offer a more modest goal it is the
abolition of nuclear which is not the
same thing as the abolition of war or
the settlement of all national
differences or indeed the common
agreement which we must try to seek and
widen but I recognize that's an old and
long-standing problem and short of
accomplishment of the just distribution
of the economic goods of the world it
seems to be very hard at least to
guarantee it and short of the solving
the long histories which imply the words
of revenge and retribution and so on the
classic arguments of the past I don't
see how we can hope to bring those to a
clear end but we can I think separate
out the idea that nuclear war will not
serve any of these interests nuclear war
will not advance the concerns of nations
and it's only use if it
you know use it all in the Arsenal's is
as a deterrent against nuclear war
itself that's to say as a hedge against
the fear that surreptitious weapons
could be found could be made which would
not which would represent a violation of
agreement and thus bring danger and if
you hold a small threshold a small
amount which is enough to cover any
plausible concealment then indeed that
to bring us knowing no advantage and can
be expected to be irrational so that I
think is the end we have to look at the
proximate end I don't deny and I would
hope we can do much better than that but
that is far enough it's much further
where we are now because where we are
now of course in a very clear position
the states may have by their action or
rather by their interaction in spite of
many provocations and many differences
have refrained from direct confrontation
between adversaries heavily armed with
nuclear weapons and that's because there
isn't strong inhibition to that use a
strong sense of survival and this we can
count all to the good but what they have
attended to say is there may be no
disaster on my watch therefore we'll
build more missiles but not use them and
the next group can decide how to solve
the matter that's been going on for 40
years the justifications for this system
and that system are so thin and so self
contradictory as you read them over the
years that it's just doing this study
now in our course and it comes ever
clear that there is no way on the level
of individual decisions to say that they
are right or wrong they're never very
right there always tendentious lee
argued the essential point appears to be
that states will spend what they can
spend five or ten percent of the gross
national product on military affairs
whatever that buys when they're a feel a
state of adversarial relationship
whatever that buys they don't ask what
it buys that's what can they spend it's
the level of effort that counts we have
two million men in armed services we've
always had two men in armed services
since 1950 and that's that's what it is
and they can be armed however powerfully
they're armed it doesn't really matter
as long as the expenditures are about
that the same when we had hundreds or
thousands
flying three tons of bombs each or
whether we have thousand three hundred
this case bombers and another thousand
missiles with the equivalent of a
million tons each it really doesn't
matter the cost is much the same and
it's that which is looked at by the
state's explanation for the order of
magnitude of what we built up it's not
measured in terms of targets its
measured on the input you need the input
you need is so and so much that's reason
we always spent that kind of sum let's
spend it again and it doesn't matter the
technicians are making it easier and
easier they have the damage with that
that's the tragedy it's not looked at in
terms of output but in terms of input
alone
other technologies will come along which
will again engage this conflict between
technology in the nation-state I don't
know which ones but I'm confident that
when we see is sufficiently grave so
that we have to take a new point it has
arisen it's not new it's again it's a
repetition of events as Vicki said of
1969 to 1970 two or three when the idea
of a defense against the delivery of
nuclear weapons was in the air
now it's gone from the air to outer
space for two of the three layers but
still much the same thing and the
trouble with it of course is not the
detail of the systems not at all I don't
want to discuss x-ray lasers or
ground-based chemical lasers or whatever
you have in mind those are all
interesting and important discussions we
should have them here but they do in
this this institution they represent the
real issue because we issue is not that
the real issue is that a defense system
genuine defense that is active defense
not deterrence the nuclear weapon style
has always been and remains based upon
marginal superiority of an installed
system my sword will pierce your shield
not every time not you're not shield
las' but the decision has always been in
the margin some little difference has
made a difference the shells penetrated
the deck of one
side but not to the other and the
remaining ships that floated were of one
guy they won the battle it's always in
this marginal distinction that every
defense offense war has been won and
that would be sole will be true for
stooging defense initiatives in space
anywhere the general picture is not the
medium that makes the difference it's
the energy and technical means placed
the disposal of those who will counter
any given system so we can expect since
we've always seen it before
a seesaw jockey which now this will be
head now that will be it and on top of
that always the proposition that nuclear
weapons are still inordinately powerful
and a small leakage of them through any
defense is devastating so you really as
everyone sales raised another race but
you've not solved the fundamental
problem the difference again is this
extraordinary order of magnitude that
nuclear energy introduces that none of
the other devices introduce at all
because they always have their match but
not there's no match to I'm afraid that
just as we have seen with the b-52 which
has only been used in combat against the
non nuclear power that's three of them
Cambodia Laos and Vietnam and the MX
missile which was built for quite a
different purpose than its present use
to close the window of vulnerability and
skitter around the southwestern desert
to avoid its target ability imitating
the submarines abandon no such
justification was present any longer
it's just mantas a better missile with a
hard target kill capability to add to
our present force and so I believe in
fact that the SDI system when it finally
is built and has its terminal defense
and a few things in orbit and so on will
not at all be regarded as adequate
against the powerful countermeasures and
increased missile powers of the powerful
superpower against us but will be used
on the side to threaten and perhaps even
to strike at somebody somewhere else in
the world who hasn't got any kind of NT
missile capability or satellites or
anything else because against such a
powered is indeed a powerful
not perhaps a winning weapon that are
very powerful activity just as the 52s
were very dropped a lot of bombs through
the monsoon on Laos and Cambodia whether
they won anything it's hard to say but
they certainly blew up a lot of
territory and I'm afraid that's we're
going to see if missile systems have
this curious life that what our systems
have this curious life once built their
utility depends on what you choose to do
it and when they're badly conceived and
they're not useful for the primary
purpose and they are so expensive you
couldn't build them for the secondary
purpose but you've gotten so there they
are I think that's the situation and I
believe the solution has got to be
measures of restraint as an initial
break to the president to the situation
restraint not just negotiate just
negotiate along negotiated mutuality
rapidly produced measures of unilateral
restraint using that word and I say this
I wanted to say it but I got in a letter
today so just comment on a formatter of
course from a very able congressman
congresswoman Patricia Schrader the
Armed Services Committee Congress and
she proposes the following scheme now I
have no way it appeals to me very much
I'm sure it is the flavour of what
eventually will work and I put it
forward to only and that means it
depends upon timing it depends upon
unity
it depends upon political circumstances
maybe none of these are propitious but
the idea is something I'll just mention
it she says let it be the sense of
Congress that on August 6 before August
6 1985 our presidential announced a
three months
withholding of all nuclear tests on
condition only that the Russians do the
same thing and if they do if he does not
certify that they have made a test then
the Congress will not allow any money to
be spent for such purposes indefinitely
looking at it every six months or a year
meanwhile negotiations begin on a more
formidable enix Comprehensive Test Ban I
think this is interesting
very mild restraint because it's
verifiable and it has the quality of an
initiative which is what we need
something to start with
not waiting to see whether the
bargaining the chips on the table can be
counted up well so unless we find such
initiatives of restraint unless we find
such minor sacrifices minor risks to
take in the face of this growing steady
never decisive but always terrible risk
which is the the single-minded arms race
for greater and greater destruction then
I think we will find no way out and I
believe one side of the other must try
this once twice many times until it
becomes caught always careful not to
compromise the peace in any substantial
way by the small but clearly indicated
direction of its proposals so I close
then very much in the same way that I
would have closed the talk in 1945
showing that one doesn't learn very much
in this world but when we came back from
New Mexico and Japan the scientists in
genuine energetic as usual
made up slogans for what should be done
in the crisis of 1945 and I think the
slogans are not bad and I'd like to
repeat them again in this time with a
little explanation and first of all we
said there will be no sir there is no
secret to this thing that's a foregone
conclusion now nobody imagines there is
it's all over the world but of course in
those days it was a big political
statement because the notion was we
would hold the secret and we alone with
the UK would be the sole nuclear powers
we said that will not work the secret
will flame will fade the secret is held
in the uranium nucleus and that is
everywhere
second we said there will be no defense
not because you know but x-ray lasers we
didn't because we knew the simple
argument I made before that defense is
in the margin but nuclear weapons are
beyond that and finally we said there
seems only one way to proceed and that
is somehow by eventual international
agreement to do away as far as we can
[Applause]
Phil and Vicky thank you for incredible
talks
mr. badge by would you honor us with
some remarks
[Applause]
traveler and friends I find myself in a
double embarrassment that almost
everything I would have liked to say has
been so much better said not only by
these two grapes because we have just
heard but more briefly but very much to
the point also in the collection that
you have in the pamphlet that is with
you my other embarrassment is quite
candidly I look like being suspect of
joining dangerous company because we all
feel the same way and well the way India
feels is not very popular in certain
quarters and I rather fear that we may
all be accused of conspiring together to
corrupt the young and to subvert the
international system as the powers that
are preferred to see it and subvert the
existing or accepted or prevailing
wisdom in Washington at least I must
confess that the presence of laymen like
myself in this very remarkable gathering
of scientists must raise two questions
at least in my mind if nachos is why I
was included
and the other is why I came the first I
would I'm sure is not because the father
of the atom bomb quoted one of our
scriptures and the Attenborough was
first exploded and I hope it is not just
because India is one of the countries in
the world that is developed they know
how of nuclear energy I wish I could
think it was an acknowledgement of
India's commitment to this cause of
finding solutions to this terrible fear
that we have all lived under in these 40
years
it is remarkable coincidence in a way
that this nuclear age is almost at the
same time began at the same time as
India's life as a modern state it was a
day of dread and glory for all of us and
the tragedy of those of us who come from
the developing world is that the glory
we had hoped to achieve from it has yet
to manifest itself but as the dread is
all too progressive
I
of course have come because we continue
to attach this very high importance and
have from the very beginning of our life
as a member of the international
community try to work for a solution
which after very few years we came to
believe lay incomplete and generalist a
moment starting with the total abolition
of all nuclear weapons we have been
pressing for this since he first
launched the proposal in the United
Nations in 1954 and followed it up with
other proposals about banning tests
about stopping vertical as well as
horizontal non-proliferation and indeed
about outlying nuclear weapons
altogether
we haven't gotten very far as you know
and there's yet another anniversary that
we will be observing this year it is the
tenth anniversary of the
non-proliferation treaty and many have
said that all right if you can't manage
the totality of the danger at least let
us limited.i
going through the self-denial process of
those countries that have not yet
developed the bomb we have not signed
the nuclear non-proliferation treaty
although we have advocated its purposes
in intentions and I think that is
because of a factor that has been
mentioned in passing or indirectly
earlier today the nation-state has
probably been responsible for more Wars
than almost any other single factor in
history and yet we who became
nation-states only a few years ago are
much too jealous and proud of that fact
to want a different order of
international affairs but what we have
always wanted is a different order of
international behavior I don't know how
many of you saw the film this afternoon
but one of those who was interviewed in
it had an interesting recollection that
the capacity to produce this weapon
really came to fruition after Germany
had already surrendered and I believe
you all had a debate as to whether to go
ahead or not
and as I think is it was it in the
recollecting this professor Wilson he
mentioned that and talking to dr.
Oppenheimer they argued back and forth
and Oppenheimer said no this is the age
of the United Nations and the United
Nations is going to usher in a new world
order which must know what this greatful
power is I take it therefore that the
scientists of that time as I see now
from scientists of today did have in
mind a very different way of Nationals
dealing with each other and if this
implies some surrender of sovereignty I
am sure it would be acceptable to nearly
every country I can think of provided
every other country would do it at the
same time and that of course is what
nobody ever is prepared do we have
therefore this continuing problem
of a few states wanting to retain their
monopoly and telling the rest of us that
we should be good boys
you pointed off out professor vas cough
that the nuclear powers have somehow
managed to keep the peace between
themselves for 40 years which is an
exceptionally long time I am reminded
that almost equal span of time prevailed
between the Congress of Vienna and the
Crimean War and yet during that period
it was the smaller nations who were
denied their rights and the concert of
Europe which ran what was then called
the civilized world it managed to keep
peace between the powers that formed
that concert but by sowing the seeds or
what proved to be the greatest wars of
history I do not think we would like to
see that experience repeated
so this so-called balance of Terror
which is trying to keep the world at
peace through fear has now reached this
ridiculous proportion where you keep
piling up the scales maybe perhaps able
to maintain their equilibrium and if you
keep piling up the scales may break and
then where will we be so those of us who
had looked for the peaceful uses of
nuclear development in which we hoped
would enable us particularly coming from
a country like India with its vast
potential but also its past problems
would help us gave to our people the
type of life that you have built for
yourselves cannot help wonder whether
it's worth the effort and whether we
must not know think of other ways of
achieving that as far as this is
concerned we have persisted as I say in
pressing for total abolition of nuclear
weapons and in the process we have been
told that we are naive
the fact of life is that a few countries
have it and they will manage and the
rest of us as I say it better behave and
others are gone to all so far as to say
that we are devious that while we
maintain this posture on the one hand we
do not sign the NPT on the other and
that we are merely allowing ourselves
the option to use the nuclear energy
from military purposes when we want to I
will build on that just paint sure one
word that our record is there for
everyone to see we have demonstrated a
capability but not developed it and we
do keep urging others to follow our
example the epithets that I used used to
be applied
two men called Gandhi
on the British thought on the one hand
naive and on the other devious I think
most if not all of us here today would
agree that looking back on his life in
his achievement he was able to do
something very new it was to make people
behave in a different way
certainly we in India somehow under his
leadership rose to a level of loyalty of
devotion of self-denial which probably
we can never do again until another
Gandhi comes along but it will give us
the hope that the rest of mankind can
under competent leadership or inspiring
leadership achieve that same type of
change and what we are really thinking
of is to change men's minds so that
nations can change their ways of dealing
with each other and we still believe
that that is possible we do not have a
gandhi to offer you
but you have so many people who can
speak that language perhaps we don't
need him
but I would like to say that the type of
ideas that I have heard today are so
much what we have tried to advocate that
is very heartening to find circles in
the United States that I can feel at
home in this matter but above all I
would say I think it was another great
man of science Sir William Osler used to
say that in science it does not matter
who first conceives of an idea what
matters is who will convince the world
I'm afraid we in India have not found it
possible to convince the world I hope
all of your scientists and above all all
of you young people here today will
succeed thank you very much
thank you for your eloquent remarks
I think we have time for some comments
and questions not too many
sir
Wow
[Music]
well yes see possibilities you know at
the end of my talk I said it really
depends on all of us the younger
generation to establish this change of
attitude towards our opponents that
would make with avoid the terrible
possibilities now this change of
attitude can how do you get it by
demonstrations by speaking out and this
is a kind of a nonviolent resistance I
mean I even I'm sure some people will
not like it what I say but I made the
kind of demonstrations to prevent
certain weapons well they usually do not
at the end really prevent them but I
think they have a very important purpose
of showing the ideas that are in the
population the resistance for example in
Europe against the erection of
intermediate-range things and similar
thing in other words although it is in
principle against the war this
demonstration as long as they are not
violent I think I and one of those
expressions that I think would help
there you cannot do it only that way you
also have to convince you have to argue
you have to get the majority on your
side but certainly so the nonviolent
demonstrations if I understand
yes in certain cases it may just be a
demonstration of the strength of your
conviction
something that I thought might be talked
about this evening that I think perhaps
we should touch on a little bit is that
is the consideration that his weapons
require builders and as we all know MIT
is one of the places where much of the
building of these weapons gets done
ideally perhaps decisions about whether
to build weapons as political decisions
should not have to concern scientists
and engineers but given the fact that
the government and our politicians
continue to be as irrational as you two
pointed out I think we are forced to
think about it and so I want to ask you
as a students who may or may not go into
science especially in a world where so
much of the funding is only available
for defense work how should we think
about this problem and especially
considering the fact that we're at MIT
and the title
this of course is not a not a new
difficult was a difficult question but
hardly a new one I'm afraid I take a
very social view of the situation I am
NOT against but hardly enthusiastic for
solutions that mean the thing goes on
just as well elsewhere where the thing
goes on but without me these are
valuable answers for individuals and I
would never deny any person that rights
and indeed necessity to work out for
every individual the comfort the degree
of opposition to the national direction
that that person wants to stand in but
really to move a laboratory from one
place to another or to do something this
kind of space it is is I think primarily
an evasion unless it is used to organize
opinion and a broader in a broader sense
so I'm not quite sure that I'm speaking
directly to the point but I think that
what I'm seeking is how to to deny the
power to the state to manufacture or
that's what it wants to do I think is
very difficult for us unless a large
majority of people agree in it then I
think was very little chance of
succeeding along those lines
and if they do agree the institutions
still exist to use the power of the
state to withhold not to spend the money
not to organize the factories to sign
the treaties and so and I feel this is a
the direction which the solution will
lie that doesn't exclude that everyone
must find a personal relationship
something see MIT is essentially
represents the United States I would
even say triple actually their property
more people against the present the same
wise against the present Trenton MIT
then somewhere else but in general MIT
represents insured represent the nation
because if we at MIT exclude every
weapon then well repeat it but he said
then we would be rivalry tower who will
have no influence so in some ways I
would say sure it's your own decision
whether you will go into that work of
this work but let me assure you if you
want to get a scientist become a
scientist you do not do it in order to
earn money of course you will earn more
money in defense but the few examples
which I have given have shown that there
are other very important tasks for
science and I think therefore we need
scientists and we need even intelligent
scientists in the weapon Department
because they cannot have an inference
there and say look what you do is not
sir I even velop the weapon developments
that are stabilizing and not be
sterilized like some of the so-called
smart so things are not that easy but
certainly you should not use not go into
science
it's abused for nuclear - also just to
keep the record straight anyone should
say MIT does not do weapons were there
at the Lincoln lab which is a set that
was quite separate installation and
therefore historic reasons radar work is
done but MIT as a university here does
not do weapons where in any case it does
not do any secret work and what once you
once you leave the domain of secrecy
it's hard to know what is a weapon and
what is not but certainly certainly no
weapons are designed or designed here
and add another thing I think an
individual has to decide to be a
pacifist or not to be a pacifist it is
to say if you if you if you oppose war
than it is logical for you to oppose
weapons work if not then somebody has to
do that work so I think there's not it's
not intrinsically immoral any more than
war itself is immoral and our societies
do engage in so I mean I think it's it's
to give yourself the luxury of saying
I'm not going to indulge in weapons work
and then no community I have anything to
do with should be involved in it is not
at least not consistent olestra pacifist
I was gonna say the question that I
heard
let me back up
so suggesting park
as an issue of personal moral response
but I think
we substitute life
that
a little lonely out there
choices
discover
much of what
only by me
while the ones
aren't there things that an institution
such as
could and should
Parrish
with those large numbers
would it make
make a choice
suggested babies
there
Steve I agree with that
and in fact the institution does is
moving in those directions there are
people in this institution who are hard
at work on exactly the kinds of
questions of movement that Vicky and
Phil described you know them they're
here on the faculty and we we are making
every effort to support them and to
expand that work and we hope it will
bear fruit and we hope that there will
be new ideas and that Student Center and
members of the community will be
involved we're doing it
excuse me I think I have a sort of
somewhat appropriate remark to me it's
not really a question but it's a sort of
more or less a statement or a request
this afternoon professor Martin Deutsch
said that in 1945 a human race was
forced to sort of speak into adulthood
by the bomb it occurred to me at that
time that to reverse the direction of
this nuclear madness we as individual
adults will have to band together and
meet the challenge at least as great as
that which threatened the nation and the
world back during World War two and
perhaps in that regard I wanted to say
that a small group of students and staff
here at MIT have been organizing some
efforts to provide additional
information to students who are
preparing to make occupational decisions
as they finish up at MIT our preliminary
focus has been to talk with students who
are considering taking jobs with
companies whose principal work is on
nuclear weapon systems we want to
continue this work and extend it among
the goals we have is for example to
provide an up-to-date and comprehensive
set of reference materials to be located
in the MIT career placement office so
that students who use the office in a
job search have access to a concise and
accurate alternative view of the many
large defense contractors who currently
recruit and provide shiny new attractive
brochures on themselves at placement
office this is just short we need help
we need help fresh ideas blood sweat and
tears to make an impact at the Institute
are our small efforts this semester have
been very encouraging it turns out that
there are a lot of students who really
haven't thought and don't have resources
available to them with their many
problem sets and with the all the
interviews that they have to go through
and getting out of here they really
haven't had any resources available to
them
to help them make more moral or ethical
choices about jobs so finally this
summer will be an ideal time to begin
our planning for the fall recruiting
period if you're interested any of you
and getting involved we need people who
can read and write who like research and
have good ideas and enthusiasm please
get in touch with me my name is Ken
Finkelstein you can reach me by leaving
a note at the Graduate Physics office
that's Ken Finkelstein and we're the
student committee on career choices
thank you I think we have come to the
end oh I'm sorry did you have a question
oh yeah but it's a little bit on a
slightly different issue so if there's
anybody who still wanted to talk about
the career thing okay well if there's
not I'll just go ahead and first of all
mr. ambassador please corrupt me I love
it but in any case it was sort of a
question for professor Morrison when you
are talking in terms of the nuclear and
conventional war differences and how we
might be able to adjust to the adjusted
going back to a conventional war
situation I'm not quite sure I got you
right but is it your opinion that it's
in any way realistic to assume that a
nation would cut back on nuclear warms
and nuclear arms cut back on them and
then sort of just feel free dabbling in
the second-rate stuff so as to speak and
if that's not the case isn't there
perhaps something wrong or something
inadequate right now with the entire
concept of a sovereign nation at all
well if to the last point I think there
probably is are quite a lot wrong with
it but I'm not in the you know I'm too
old to engage in the projection of large
historical changes they might come but I
don't know when they'll come
but I do find it not at all difficult to
see I mean restraint is the essence of
contemporary war we've seen it we've
fought a war which we were rather badly
beaten but we very rarely can even only
considered extending that war because of
the obvious fact that if we extended
that weren't the nuclear direction that
escalated it we would have lost more
than we would've gained and that option
is available at any point in anywhere I
look forward to the possibility that
that could happen that even the great
states would confront each other in war
recognizing that if they were to open a
nuclear war they would lose something
more than the issues at stake
we are happy and that they are not near
neighbors they don't have you know it's
not a question to take Washington
tomorrow the only way in which the
United States is endangered is through
nuclear weapons the interior the zone of
the interior we've given up this great
geopolitical advantage for the sake of
waging strategic war far away which is
not a very sensible thing to do but
that's another talk that I won't give
now but but probably probably the war of
the total war with unconditional
surrender is out that's finished
in during World War two we had the
Manhattan Project which was a research
project which people didn't know what
the results would be but if they were
successful would certainly and in fact
we can see from with our hindsight
certainly changed the nature of warfare
and world politics today in the United
States we have Star Wars or the
Strategic Defense Initiative depending
on whether you're for or against it used
one one name or the other which again is
at the moment is a research program
which if it was successful in a totally
total defense if you will
what again changed the nature of warfare
and world politics and it seems to me
that some of the arguments for and
against Star Wars could have been
applied back during World War two for
the Manhattan Project do you think
that's that's valid what similarities
and differences do you see well is it
extremely interesting logical argument
and I certainly would like to give you a
large big grand a for debating merit I
think it's extremely well put but as a
matter of fact I think you're selling to
some petrol motion machine I don't agree
I don't disagree at all and if you would
explain to me how it's going to make a
nuclear weapons obsolete I'll sign on to
it it just won't well and the reason it
won't is excuse me it's not even
logically coherent the what it really
meant to say was logically it'll make
ballistic missiles impotent and obsolete
that's the most complained
maybe it'll add cruise missiles but I'll
darned if I see how it's going to work
on submarine torpedoes
it isn't just discussing the right
so I personally think it's a bill of
goods I mean that's everything that
Manhattan Project was that when somebody
was willing enough to put in ten million
dollars into it in the OSRD probably
Conant and Bush and then it went and
then ferry made the chain reaction after
that look pretty clear another five
hundred million and so it went well
that's what has to be done here by the
way the chips are now much bigger for
much less delivery
[Music]
well I'm sorry that my talk wasn't good
enough because that's that's what I
that's what I thought I said you know I
mean the answer is I agree with you with
some kind of exaggeration I would say
the arms race is a symptom I mean if
nation if two superpowers are really
capable of producing and increasing
armaments 50 times larger than complete
destruction I mean something is wrong I
mean this is the mental disease I was
talking about and what I was trying to
say maybe not clearly that was that
would you need the change of attitude
that the arms I mean not only you cannot
turn around the arms race but you will
get a stable instead of metastable
situation because the arms race the
metal stable situation only if you
change the attitude towards our
adversary in both directions and if you
mean that I fully agree maybe there is a
difference between Vicki and me because
I really don't think I agree with that
you say I really think it's not the risk
of war that can't be the expectation
and the expectation is very high even if
the risk is small because the damage is
so great if it occurs in the wrong way
and it's against this expectation that
I'm primarily acting I don't expect to
see you know an end to war it might be
the beam and as he says to total war
with unconditional surrender demands but
that's in the political domain what I'm
what I mean is war with the maximum use
of the technical capabilities of modern
society I don't think that we could
stand that and I think that the only the
way to get around it is to remove the
serious consequences as far as possible
by reducing nuclear armaments and
they're triggering us you know they're
the readiness they're instability their
first strike advantages all these issues
that have come up in the theology of
yes yes
well
I just don't agree with that I think
that you're wrong I think with the the
concrete circumstances what we call the
capabilities are more determining the
judgments of intentions and rules of
engagement that's characteristic of most
war and I think if you cut this thing
now I agree a factor of two will make a
bit of difference from my point of view
it's got but it only shows direction
therefore any small change is valuable
now because it signals direction but if
you cut it by an order of magnitude
which is what I am speaking of there I
think it makes a big difference it no
longer is decisive in and of itself it
no longer represents anything but
another gamble if you try to escalate
now who will make the most weapons and
who will do them first and who will land
them best that's putting the whole war
on a certain gamble of novel technology
which is very hard to do which I don't
anticipate people would manage so I
think that it is possible without in
increasing the risk of major of
superpower conflict to reduce the number
of weapons and very greatly reduce the
instability of the situation I'll take
just one more question I would end it
there's a moral distinction
I don't I don't know if there's a
practical distinction of great
importance namely important to 3 billion
999 million people if I take your
numbers
I mean look we've seen 20 million people
killed roughly speaking in wars since
World War two maybe only 15 no it's
terrible but you think that the presence
of nuclear power superpower armament has
made that less likely I think it's
contributed a great deal to it client
states have everywhere in put to work
warring because the big boys didn't want
to engage into themselves thank you very
much thank you for coming
[Applause]